The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
is going to be
our last pass at bound states.
So starting next week or
actually starting next lecture,
we're going to
look at scattering.
Scattering's going to be great.
But we need to close
out bound states.
So today's topic
is the finite well,
finite the potential well.
We've sort of
sketched this when we
looked at qualitative structure
of wave functions of energy
eigenstates.
But we're going to
solve the system today.
So good.
So the system we're
interested in is going to be--
The system we're
interested in is
going to be a system
with a finite depth
and a finite width.
And I'll go into detail and
give you parameters in a bit.
But first I want
to just think about
how do we find energy
eigenfunctions of a potential
of this form, v of x, which
is piecewise constant.
So first off, is this is a
terribly realistic potential?
Will you ever in the
real world find a system
that has a potential which
is piecewise constant?
Probably not.
It's discontinuous.
Right?
So it's rather unphysical.
But it's a very
useful toy model.
So for example, if you take
a couple of capacitor plates,
then you can induce a situation
where the electric field
is nonzero in between
the capacitor plates
and zero outside of
the capacitor plates.
Right.
So at a superficial level,
this looks discontinuous.
It looks like the
electric field is--
But actually, you know
that microscopically there
are a bunch of
charges, and everything
is nice and continuous
except for the behavior
right at the charges.
So but it's reasonable
to model this
as a step function
for an electric field.
So this is going to
be an idealization,
but it's going to be a
very useful idealization,
the constant potential.
OK.
So what's the equation?
What are we trying to do?
We want to find the energy
eigenstates for this
because we want to study
the time evolution.
And the easiest way to solve
the Schrodinger equation,
the time evolution equation,
is to expand an energy
eigenstates.
So the equation we want to solve
is energy eigenvalue times phi
e of x is equal to minus
h bar squared on 2m phi
e phi prime plus v of x.
And I'm going to put it in
the form we've been using.
Phi prime prime e of x
is equal to 2m upon h bar
squared v of x minus e.
OK.
So this is the
form that I'm going
to use today to solve for the
energy eigenvalue equations.
e is some constant.
Do you expect the allowed
energies to be arbitrary?
No.
They should be discrete.
Yeah, exactly.
So we expect that there should
be discrete lowest energy
state, some number
of bound states.
And then, eventually,
if the energy
is greater than the
potential everywhere,
the energies will be continuous.
Any energy will be allowed
above the potential.
So we'll have a continuum of
states above the potential.
And we'll have a discrete
set of bound states--
Probably, it's reasonable
to expect some finite number
of bound states
just by intuition.
--from the infinite well.
So we expect to have a finite
number of discrete energies
and then a continuous set
of energies above zero.
So if this is the asymptotic
value potential of zero.
OK.
And this is intuition
gained from our study
of qualitative structure
of energy eigenfunctions.
So we are going to talk
today about the bound states.
And in recitation,
leaders should
discuss the continuum
above zero energy.
OK.
So to solve for the actual
energy eigenfunctions
and the energy eigenvalues,
what we need to do
is we need to
solve this equation
subject to some
boundary conditions.
And the boundary conditions
we're going to want to solve
are going to be finite.
So it's normalizable infinity.
The solution should
be vanishing far away.
And the wave function
should be everywhere smooth.
Well, at least it
should be continuous.
So let's talk about what
exactly boundary conditions we
want to impose.
And so in particular,
we're going
to want to solve for the energy
eigenfunctions in the regions
where the potential is constant
and then patch together
solutions at these boundaries.
We know how to solve for
the energy eigenfunctions
when the potential is constant.
What are the energy
eigenfunctions?
Yeah.
Suppose I have a potential,
which is constant.
v is equal to 0.
What are the energy
eigenfunctions
of this potential?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, e to the ikx.
Yeah.
Now, what if I
happen to tell you--
So we're at h bar
squared k squared upon 2m
is equal to the energy.
Suppose I happen to tell you
that here's the potential.
And I want to find the
solution in this region
where the energy is here
less than the potential.
What are the solutions?
That's a second order
differential equation.
There should be two solutions.
What are the solutions to that
differential equation when
the energy is less
than the potential?
AUDIENCE: Decaying and growing.
PROFESSOR: Decaying and
growing exponentials.
Exactly. e to the plus alpha
x and e to the minus alpha x.
And the reason is
these are sinusoidal,
and these have the
opposite concavity.
They are growing and
dying exponentials.
Cool?
OK.
So we've studied that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't
that be a phi e of x?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Oh, oh, yes, indeed.
Sorry.
Thank you.
Phi e of x.
It's early, and I'm still
working on the coffee.
It won't take long.
Good.
So we know how to solve the
energy eigenvalue equation
in all these regions where
the potential is constant.
So our job is going to be to
find a solution where we patch
them together at
these interfaces.
We patch them together.
And what condition
should we impose?
So the basic condition
is going to be
continuity of the wave
functions phi e of x.
And so what are the
conditions that we need?
Well, if v of x--
Here's the way I like
to think about this.
Suppose v of x is continuous.
So if the potential
is continuous, then
what can you say?
You can say that phi prime prime
is a continuous function times
phi of x.
So very roughly, if
we look at a region
where phi isn't varying
very much, so if we
have a potential that's
varying in some way, then
phi prime prime, in a
region where it's not
varying much compared to its
value as a function of x,
does something
smooth because it's
varying with the potential.
And so phi prime,
which is just going
to be the integral of this--
The integral of
a smooth function
is again a smooth function.
--and phi, the integral
of that function
is also going to be a
nice, smooth function.
OK?
I've drawn it badly, but--
So the key thing here is that
if the potential is continuous,
then the energy eigenfunction
has a second derivative, which
is also continuous.
That means its first
derivative is continuous.
So that means the function
itself is continuous.
Everyone agree with this?
Questions?
So in regions where the
potential's continuous,
the wave function and its
first two derivatives all
have to be continuous.
On the other hand, suppose
the potential has a step.
v of x has a step discontinuity.
OK.
So the potential
does one of those.
So what does that tell
you about phi prime prime?
It's a function of x.
So for example, let's
look at that first step.
Suppose the potential is that
first step down by some amount.
Then phi prime prime is going
to decrease precipitously
at some point.
And the actual amount
that it decreases
depends on the value of
phi because the change
in the potential time is
the actual value of phi.
And if that's true of
phi prime prime what can
you say of phi prime?
So this is discontinuous.
Phi prime of x,
however, is the integral
of this discontinuous function.
And what does it do?
Well, it's linearly
increasing in this region
because its derivative
is constant.
And here, it's linearly
increasing less.
So it's not differentiably
smooth, but it's continuous.
And then let's look at the
actual function phi of x.
OK.
What is it doing?
Well, it's quadratic.
And then here it's quadratic
a little less afterwards.
But that still
continuous because it's
the integral of a
continuous function.
Everyone we cool with that?
So even when we have a step
discontinuity in our potential,
we still have that
our derivative
and the value of the
function are continuous.
Yeah?
However, imagine the potential
has this delta function.
Let's just really push it.
What happens if our potential
has a delta function
singularity?
Really badly discontinuous.
Then what can you say about phi
prime prime as a function of x?
So it has a delta
function, right?
So the phi prime prime has to
look like something relatively
slowly varying, and then
a step delta function.
So what does that tell you
about the derivative of the wave
function?
It's got a step function.
Exactly.
Because it's the integral of
this, and the integral is 0, 1.
Whoops.
I missed.
So this is a delta.
This is a step.
And then the wave
function itself
is, well, it's the integral
of a step, so it's continuous.
Sorry.
It's certainly not
differentiable.
Its derivative is discontinuous.
Well, it's differentiable
but its derivative's
not supposed to be.
It is not continuous, indeed.
So this is continuous.
So we've learned something
nice, that unless our potential
is so stupid as to have
delta functions, which
sounds fairly unphysical--
We'll come back to that
later in today's lecture.
--unless our potential
has delta functions,
the wave function and its first
derivative must be smooth.
Yeah.
This is just from the
energy eigenvalue equation.
Now, we actually argued this
from the well definedness
and the finiteness
of the expectation
value of the momentum
earlier in the semester.
But I wanted to give
you this argument for it
because it's going to
play a useful role.
And it also tells us that if
we do have a delta function
singularity in the
potential, then the upshot
is that the wave function
is going to be continuous,
but its first
derivative will not.
Its first derivative will
jump at the wave function.
And that means that
the wave function--
Let me draw this
slightly differently.
--the wave function
will have a kink.
Its derivative will
not be continuous.
OK.
So anywhere where we
have a delta function
in the potential, we will have
a kink in the wave function
where the first derivative
is discontinuous.
Cool?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What does
that mean as far
as the expectation
value of the momentum?
PROFESSOR: Ah, that's
an excellent question.
So what do you expect to
happen at such a point?
AUDIENCE: Well, your
momentum blows up.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So we're going to
have some pathologies
with expectation
values in the momentum.
Let's come back to that when we
talk about the delta function
potential, which should
be at the end of today.
Hold that question in
the back of your head.
It's a good question.
Other questions?
OK.
So what we're going to do now
is we're going to use, you know,
math to find the
energy eigenfunctions
and eigenvalues for the
finite well potential, i.e.
we're going to solve
this equation contingent
on the boundary
conditions that the wave
function and its derivative
are smooth everywhere.
And in particular, they must
be smooth here and here.
I mean they've got to
be smooth everywhere.
We know what the
solution is inside here.
solution is in here.
All we have to worry about is
what happens at the interface.
And we're going to use
smoothness of the wave function
and its derivative to
impose conditions that
allow us to match
across that step.
Everyone cool with that?
OK.
So let's do it.
By the way, just
a quick side note.
Let me give you a definition.
I've used this
phrase many times,
but I haven't given
you a definition of it.
So I've used the
phrase, bound state.
And its opposite is
called a scattering state.
So here's what I mean
by a bound state.
Intuitively, a
bound state, if you
think about this
classically, imagine
I have a potential well.
And I have a marble,
and I let go from here.
This marble is bound.
Right?
It's never getting
out of the well.
It's stuck.
Yeah?
And so I would call
that a bound marble.
On the other hand, a marble
that I give a huge kick to,
big velocity so
that it can get out,
well then it's not bound
to this potential well.
So I'll call that a scattering
state just to give it a name.
And next lecture we'll see why
we call it a scattering state.
The important thing is
that bound configurations
of a classical
potential are things
basically in a well
that are stuck.
OK.
So the quantum version of that
statement is the following.
Suppose I take this
potential, and I
treat it quantum mechanically,
and I consider a state
with total energy like this.
Well, among other
things, the total energy
is less than the value of
the potential asymptotically
far away.
So what is the form
of a wave function
in this region with this energy?
Exponential, right?
It's e to the
minus some alpha x,
where alpha squared is roughly
the difference, alpha x.
And out here it's going to
be e to the plus alpha x.
And that's for normalizability.
We want to have a single
particle in this state.
So what that tells us is that
the wave function falls off
in these classically disallowed
regions exponentially.
And so the probability
of measuring the particle
at an arbitrarily far
position goes to zero.
And it goes to zero
exponentially rapidly.
Cool?
So I will call a bound state, a
quantum bound state, an energy
eigenstate, such that
the probability falls off
exponentially as we go far
away from wherever we think
is an interesting point,
like the bottom of the well.
Cool?
A bound state is
just a state which
is exponentially localized.
If you put it there,
it will stay there.
Yeah.
And it's important that
when I say a bound state
I'm talking about
energy eigenstates.
And the reason is this.
Bound state equals
energy eigenstate.
The reason is that,
consider by contrast
a free particle,
so a free particle
with constant potential.
What are the wave functions?
What are the energy
eigenfunctions?
Well, they're plane waves.
Right.
So are these bound states?
No.
Good.
OK.
On the other hand,
I claimed that I
can build a wave packet, a
perfectly reasonable wave
packet, which is a Gaussian.
OK.
This is some wave
function, psi of x times 0.
It's a Gaussian.
It's nice and narrow.
Is that a bound state?
Well, it's localized
at this moment in time.
But will it remain, and in
particular its probability
distribution, which
is this thing norm
squared is localized in space--
Sorry.
This was zero.
--it's localized in space.
The probability of
it being out here
is not just
exponentially small, it's
Gaussian so it's e to
the minus x squared.
It's really not out here.
But what happens if I let go?
What happens if I look
at the system at time t?
It's going to spread out.
It's going to disperse.
We're going to talk about
that in more detail later.
So it's going to spread out.
And eventually, it will get
out arbitrarily far away
with whatever probably you like.
So the probability distribution
is not time invariant.
That is to say it's
not a stationary state.
It's not an energy eigenstate.
Saying something is bound
means that it never gets away.
So bound states are
specifically energy eigenstates
that are strictly
localized, that fall off
at least exponentially as
we go away from the origin.
Cool?
It's just terminology, what
I mean by a bound state.
Questions?
OK.
So let's talk about
the finite well.
So I need to give you
definitions of the parameters.
Let's draw this more precisely.
Here's my well.
Asymptotically, the
potential is zero.
The potential depth, I'm
going to call minus v naught.
OK.
And I'm going to center
the well around zero.
And I'll call the
sides minus l and l.
And I want to find bound
states of this potential,
just like we found bound states
of the harmonic oscillator,
i.e.
states with energy e,
which is less than zero.
So these are going to give
us bound states because we're
going to have exponential
fall offs far away.
So a couple of things to note.
The first is on,
I think, problem
set three or four you
showed that if you
have a potential,
which is symmetric,
which is even, under x goes
to minus x, then every energy
eigenfunction, or at least
every bound state energy
eigenfunction, every energy
eigenfunction can be written
as phi e symmetric or
phi e anti-symmetric.
So it's either even or odd.
It's either even or odd under
the exchange of x to minus x.
So when our potential
is symmetric,
the wave function or the
energy eigenfunctions
are either symmetric
or anti-symmetric.
OK.
So we want to solve for
the actual eigenfunctions.
So we want to solve
that equation.
And we have this
nice simple fact
that we know the
solutions in this region.
We know the general
solution in this region.
So I'm going to call these
regions one, two, and three,
just to give them a name.
So in region one--
That's actually sort of stupid.
Let's call this inside,
left, and right.
Good.
OK.
So let's look at this equation.
We have two cases.
If the energy is greater than
the potential in some region,
then this is of the
form phi prime prime
is equal to energy
greater than potential.
This is a negative number.
And so this is a
minus k squared phi.
And we get exponentials.
And if, on the other hand,
e is less than v of x, then
phi prime prime is equal
to plus alpha squared phi.
I should say oscillator.
And in particular here, I want
the k squared is equal to 2m
upon h bar squared.
It's just the
coefficient v minus e.
And alpha squared is equal to
2m over h bar squared e minus v.
OK.
So let's apply that here.
So in this region, we're
going to get oscillations
because we're in a classically
allowed region, where
the energy is greater
than the potential.
So we'll get
oscillatory solutions.
And the salient value
of k inside, is k
is equal to the square root
of 2m over h bar squared times
v minus e.
So that's minus v naught.
What did I do?
I did.
It's e minus v. I thank you.
Yes.
And I want the other one to
be l so it'd be minus v. Good.
Good.
Excellent.
So root 2 over h bar squared.
And now we have e
minus v naught, which
is the actual value of
e, which is negative.
Right?
But minus v naught
or plus v naught
is positive and
greater in magnitude.
So this is a nice
positive number,
and k is the square root of it.
This is controlling
how rapidly the wave
function oscillates
in this region.
Similarly, out here we
have alpha is equal to--
Well, here the
potential is zero.
So it's particularly easy.
Alpha is equal to
the square root of 2m
upon h bar squared of--
Now z minus e is zero minus
e, which is a negative number.
So we can just write
e absolute value.
So we can write the general
solution of this eigenfunction,
of this eigenvalue equation,
as phi e of x is equal to--
Let's break it up into
inside and outside.
Well, inside we know, since it's
constant with this value of k,
we get superpositions of
oscillatory solutions.
It' a second-order
difference equation.
There are two solutions and
two integration constants.
So first we have a cosine
of kx plus b sine kx.
This is inside.
And then on the left
we have a combination
of exponentially growing and
exponentially decreasing.
So the exponentially
growing is e to the alpha x
plus de the minus alpha x.
And on the right,
similarly by symmetry,
we have some combination of e--
But I don't want to call
it the energy, so I'll
call it the curly e.
--to the alpha x plus
fe to the minus alpha x.
OK.
So that's the general solution.
We solve the problem as a
superposition of the two
oscillatory solutions
or a superposition
of the two exponentially
growing and damped solutions
or exponentially
growing and collapsing
functions on the left and right.
Questions?
So a couple of things
to note at this point.
So the first is we have
boundary conditions to impose.
We have boundary conditions
at these two interfaces.
But we also have boundary
conditions off in infinity.
What are the boundary
conditions at infinity?
Yeah, exactly.
It should vanish.
So we want the system
to be normalizable.
So normalizable is
going to say that phi
goes to zero at minus infinity.
Phi of x goes to minus infinity
goes to zero, which it equals.
And phi of x goes to plus
infinity should also be zero.
OK.
And then we're
also going to have
the conditions at
the left boundary,
and we're going
to have conditions
at the right boundary.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So what are the boundary
condition at the left boundary
condition?
So first off, what are
the boundary conditions
we want to impose at the
left and right boundaries?
AUDIENCE: Continuous.
PROFESSOR: Continuous,
and the derivative
should be continuous.
Exactly.
So we have that phi is
continuous, and phi prime--
Good god.
--phi prime is continuous.
Similarly, phi continuous,
phi prime continuous.
OK.
Do we have enough
boundary conditions
to specify our function?
So we have now for
our solution, we
have six undetermined
coefficients.
And we have six
boundary conditions.
So that looks good.
Are they all independent?
Ponder that one.
So in particular, let's
start with the normalizable.
So in order for phi to go to
zero at minus infinity deep
out on the left,
what should be true?
Yeah, d goes to zero.
Oops, equals zero.
And on the right?
Yeah, that curly
e equals 0, which
is nice so I don't ever
have to write it again.
So that's zero.
And that's zero.
OK.
That's good.
We can take advantage
though of something nice.
We know that the
wave function has
to be either symmetric
or anti-symmetric.
Right?
So we can exploit
that and say, look,
the wave function is going to
be different from our boundary
conditions, but
it's a true fact,
and we can take advantage of it.
We can use the
parody of the well.
I can never--
So we can use the
parody of the potential
to say that the system is either
symmetric or anti-symmetric.
And these are often
said as even or odd
because the function
will be, as a function
of x, either even or odd.
You either pick up a
minus sign or a plus sign
under taking x to minus x.
So if the system is
even, what can we
say about these coefficients?
What must be true
of b, for example?
AUDIENCE: It's zero.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So b equals 0.
And what else?
AUDIENCE: It equals f.
PROFESSOR: This equals f.
Yeah, good.
OK.
This equals f.
And if the system
is anti-symmetric,
then a equal to 0.
And we see that c
is equal to minus f.
Yeah?
So that's a useful
simplification.
So it's easy to see that we
could do this either way.
We could do either
symmetric or anti-symmetric.
I'm going to, for
simplicity in lecture,
focus on the even case.
b is equal to 0, and
c is equal to minus f.
Sorry, c is equal to f.
So plus c.
So now we're
specifically working
with the even solutions.
And on your problem set,
you'll repeat this calculation
for the odd functions.
So we're going to focus
on the even solutions.
And now what we have
to do is we have
to impose the boundary
conditions for phi and phi
prime.
So that's easy enough.
We have the function.
All we have to do is impose
that the values are the same.
So for example, let's focus on
the left boundary conditions.
Sorry.
Let's focus on the
right because I
don't want to deal
with that minus sign.
So let's focus on the
right boundary conditions.
So this is x is equal to plus l.
So when x is equal to
plus l, what must be true?
Phi and phi prime
must be continuous.
So what's phi?
So phi is equal to--
Well, from inside,
it's a cosine of kl.
Yeah.
And b is gone because we're only
looking at the even functions.
On the right, however, it's
equal to c e to the minus alpha
l because we're evaluating
at the right boundary.
Yeah?
OK.
So this is cool.
It allows us to determine
c in terms of a.
And if we solve that
equation for c in terms of a,
we'll get an
eigenfunction, phi even,
with one overall
normalization coefficient, a.
And then we can fix
that to whatever
it has to be so that
everything integrates to one.
Yeah?
So that seems fine.
It seems like we can
solve for c in terms of a.
c is equal to--
This is weight.
Well, OK.
So c is equal to a cosine
e to the plus alpha l.
On the other hand, we also have
a condition on the derivative.
And the condition
on the derivative
is that phi prime is continuous.
And the derivative of
this, well that's easy.
It's the derivative of cosine.
So this is going
to be minus sine.
But we pull out a factor
of k, because we're
taking derivative
with respect to x.
Minus k is sine of kx.
Evaluate it out, sine of kl, l.
And this is going
to be equal to minus
alpha c e to the minus alpha l.
AUDIENCE: You forgot an a.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
There should be an a.
Thank you.
OK.
So but now we've got
a problem because this
says that c is equal to minus
a times k over alpha sine
of kl times e to the alpha l.
And that's bad
because c can't be
equal to two different
numbers at the same time.
There's a certain monogamy
of mathematical equations.
It just doesn't work.
So how do we deal with this?
Well, let's think about
what these equations would
have meant.
Forget this one for
the moment, and just
focus on that first expression.
I'm going to rewrite
this slightly.
a cosine of kl.
OK.
So what does this
expression say?
Well, it seems like
it's just saying
if we fix c to be equal to this
value, for fixed value of kappa
l and alpha, then
there's a solution.
However, what is k?
What are k and alpha.
k and alpha are
functions of the energy.
So it would seem from
this point of view,
like for any value
of the energy,
we get a solution
to this equation.
Everyone see that?
But we know that can't
possibly be right
because we expect the
solutions to be discrete.
We don't expect
any value of energy
to lead to a solution of the
energy eigenvalue equation.
There should be only
discrete set of energies.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Did you
pick up an extra minus
sign in the expression for c?
PROFESSOR: You do.
Thank you.
The sign's cancel.
Yes, excellent.
I've never written this
equation in my life.
So thank you.
Yes, extra minus sign.
So what's going on here?
Well, what we see is
that we've written down
the general form
of the solution.
Here were imposing that we've
already imposed the condition
that we're normalizable
at infinity.
Here, we're imposing
the continuity condition
on the right.
And if we impose just
the continuity condition
for the wave function,
we can find a solution.
Similarly, if we impose only
the continuity condition
for the derivative,
we can find a solution
for arbitrary values
of the energy.
But in order to find
a solution where
the wave function and its
derivative are both continuous,
it can't be true that the energy
takes just any value because it
would tell you that c
takes two different values.
Right?
So there's a
consistency condition.
For what values of energy or
equivalently, for what values
of k and alpha are these
two expressions equal
to the same thing?
Cool?
So we can get that
by saying, look
we want both of these
equations to be true.
And this is easy.
I can take this equation and
divide it by this equation.
And I will lose
my coefficients c.
I will lose my coefficients a.
What do we get?
On the right hand side, we get--
And I'm going to put a
minus sign on everything.
So minus, minus, minus.
So if we take this equation and
we divide it by this equation,
on the right hand
side, we get alpha,
because the c
exponential drops off.
And on this side, we lose the a.
We get a k.
And then we get sine over
cosine of kl, also known
as tangent of kl.
Here we have a kl.
Here we have a k.
These are all
dimensionful things.
Let's multiply
everything by an l.
And this is nice
and dimensionless.
Both sides are dimensionless.
So we get this condition.
This is the
consistency condition,
such that both the wave
function and its derivative
can be continuous at
the right boundary.
OK?
And this is a pretty
nontrivial condition.
It says, given a value
of k, you can always
determine the value of alpha,
such as this equation as true.
But remember that k and
alpha are both known
functions of the energy.
So this is really an equation, a
complicated, nonlinear equation
for the energy.
So this is equal to a horrible
expression, a condition, badly
nonlinear, in fact,
transcendental condition
on the energy.
And where's it coming from?
It's coming from normalizability
and continuity everywhere.
And a useful thing
to check, and I
invite you to do
this on your own,
is to check that the boundary
conditions at the left wall
give the same expression.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For our final
form of that equation,
is there a reason that we prefer
to multiply both sides by l
than divide both sides by k?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And it'll be little more
obvious in a second.
But here's the reason.
So let's divide through by l.
This is the form that we got.
What are the units?
What are the dimensions
of this expression?
k is a wave number, so it
has units of 1 upon length.
Right?
And that's good because that's
1 upon length times the length,
and you'd better have something
dimensionless inside a tangent.
But it seems there are two
things to say about this.
The first is it seems like l
is playing an independent role
from k in this equation.
But this is dimensionless.
These are both dimensionful
units of 1 over length.
So we can make the entire
expression dimensionless
and make it clear that k and l
don't have an independent life.
The dimensionless quantity,
kl, times the tangent
of that dimensionless
quantity is
equal to this
dimensionless quantity.
So the reason that this
is preferable is twofold.
First off, it makes it
sort of obvious that k
and l, you can't vary them
independently in this sense.
But the second is that it makes
it nice and dimensionless.
And you'll always,
whenever possible,
want to put things in
dimensionless form.
I mean it's just
multiplying by l.
So it's obviously
not all that deep.
But it's a convenient bit
of multiplication by l.
Other questions?
OK.
So where are we?
So I'd like to find the
solutions of this equation.
So again, just to--
Let me write this slightly
differently where k squared is
equal to 2m upon h
bar squared v0 plus e.
And alpha squared is equal
to 2m upon h bar squared e,
the positive value of e.
So this is a really complicated
expression as a function of e.
So I'd like to solve for the
actual energy eigenvalues.
I want to know what are the
energy eigenvalues of the bound
states of the finite potential
well, as a function of l,
for example.
Sadly, I can't
solve this equation.
It's a transcendental equation.
It's a sort of canonically
hard problem to solve.
You can't write down a closed
from expression for it.
However, there are a bunch
of ways to easily solve it.
One is take your
convenient nearby laptop.
Open up Mathematica, and ask it
to numerically find solutions
to this.
And you can do this.
It's a good exercise.
I will encourage you to
do so on your problem set.
And in fact, on
the problem set, it
asks you to do a calculation.
And it encourages you
do it using Mathematica.
Let me rephrase the
statement in the problem set.
It would be crazy for you to
try to do it only by hand.
You should do it by
hand and on computer
because they're both easy.
And you can check
against each other.
They make different
things obvious.
This should be your default is
to also check on Mathematica.
The second thing we can do is we
can get a qualitative solution
of this equation
just graphically.
And since this is such a useful
technique, not just here,
but throughout physics
to graphically solve
transcendental
equations, I'm going
to walk through it a little bit.
So this is going to be
the graphical solution.
And we can extract,
it turns out,
an awful lot of the
physics of these energy
eigenstates and their
energies through
this graphical technique.
So the first thing
is I write this
in nice, dimensionless form.
And let me give those
dimensionless variables a name.
Let me call kl is equal to
z, just define a parameter z.
And alpha l is a parameter y.
And I want to note that z
squared plus y squared is
equal to a constant, which
is, I will call if you just
plug these guys out, kl
squared plus al squared.
That's easy.
Kl squared is this
guy times l squared.
Al squared is this
And so the e and
the minus e cancel
when we add them together.
So we just get 2mv0 over h
bar squared times l squared.
So 2m upon h bar
squared l squared v0.
And I'm going to call
this r naught in something
of a pathological
abusive notation.
OK.
So this is our expression.
And I actually want to
call this r0 squared.
I know.
It's awful.
But the reason I
want to do this is
that this is the
equation for a circle.
Yeah?
And a circle has a radius.
The thing that goes
over here is r squared.
OK.
So at this point, you're
thinking like, come on, circle.
So let's plot it.
So how are we going to
solve this equation?
Here's what I want to solve.
I have now two equations
relating z and y.
We have that from this equation
z tangent z is equal to y.
And from this equation we
have that z squared plus y
squared is a
constant r0 squared.
Where r0 squared depends on
the potential and the width
in a very specific way, on
the depth of the potential
and the width in a
very specific way.
So we want to find--
Bless you.
--simultaneously, we want to
find simultaneous solutions
of these two equations.
Yeah?
So that's relatively easy.
So here's y, and here's z.
So this equation has solutions.
Any time that y
plus z squared is
equal to r0 squared, that means
any time we have a circle.
So solutions for fixed
values of r0 lie on circles.
Oh, I really should have
drawn this under here.
Sorry.
y and z.
So those are the circles.
Notice that I'm only focusing
on y and z, both positive.
Why?
Not yz, but W-H-Y .
Why am I focusing
on the variables y
and z being positive?
Because we started out defining
them in terms of k and l,
which were both positive,
and alpha and l,
which were both positive.
Can we find solutions
to this equation
that have x and y negative?
Sure.
But they don't mean anything in
terms of our original problem.
So to map onto solutions
of our original problem,
we want to focus on the
positive values of y and z.
Cool?
OK.
So that's this one.
The solutions lie on circles.
So given a value of y, you
can find a solution of z.
But we want to also find a
solution of this equation.
And this equation is a little
more entertaining to plot.
Here's y.
Here's z.
So what does z tangent z do?
Oh, shoot.
I want to plot y vertical.
Otherwise, it's going
to a giant pain.
Happily, this plot
can be left identical.
Let's plot y vertically.
So the reason I want
to plot y vertically
is that this is z tangent z.
So first off, what does
tangent z look like?
Yeah.
This is awesome.
Yeah, it looks like this.
Yes, exactly.
So tangent is sine over cosine.
Sine is zero, and cosine is one.
So it does this, as
you go to a value
where the argument, let's
call the argument z.
So if we just plot tangent--
OK.
So when z is equal to pi over
2, then the denominator cosine
vanishes, and that diverges.
Oops.
OK.
So here's pi over 2.
Here's pi.
Whoops.
Pi, pi over 2, and here's
3pi over 2, and so on.
Now, we're only interested
in the first quadrant.
So I'm just ignore down here.
OK.
So this is pi over 2.
This is pi, 3pi over 2.
OK.
But this is not what
we're interested in.
We're not interested
in tangent of z.
We're interested in z tangent z.
And what does z
tangent z look like?
Well, it's basically the same.
Right?
z tangent z, it has an
extra factor of zero here
and remains extra
small at the beginning.
But it still curves
off roughly like this.
And z is just nice
and linear, nice
and regular throughout this.
So it doesn't change
the fact that we
have a divergence at pi over 2.
And it doesn't change the fact
that it vanishes again at pi
and becomes positive again.
It just changes the
shape of the curve.
And in fact, the way it
changes the shape of the curve
is this becomes a little
fatter around the bottom.
It's just a little more round.
And when we get out
to large values of z,
it's going to have a
more pronounced effect
because that slope
is, at every example
where it crosses z, that
slope is getting larger
because the coefficient
of z is getting larger.
OK.
So it's just going to
get more and more sharp.
But anyway, with all
that said, here's 0.
Here's pi.
Here's pi over 2.
Here's 3pi over 2.
The second plot we want
to plot, y is z tangent z.
We know how to plot this.
Cool?
And what we want to find
are simultaneous solutions
of this, values of y and z, for
which this equation is solved
and this equation is solved
for the same value of y and z.
This is a graphical solution.
So let's combine them together.
And the combined
plots look like this.
First we have pi over 2.
So let's plot the tangents.
And then we have these circles
for various values of r.
So for a particular
value of r, for example,
suppose this is the value of r.
This is r0.
So how many
solutions do we have?
One.
One set of common
points where at y and z
solve both equations.
So we immediately learn
something really lovely.
What happens to the
radius of that circle
as I make the well deeper?
Yeah, as I make the well
deeper, that means v0 gets
larger and larger magnitude,
the radius gets larger.
So does the circle.
So if I make the well deeper,
I make this the circle larger.
Will I still have a solution?
Yeah, I'll still
have a solution.
But check this out.
Now, I'll have a new solution.
And you can even see the
critical value of the depth
and the width of the well.
In order to have exactly a
new bound state appearing,
what must the value of r0 be?
Well, it's got to be that value,
such that r0 squared is pi.
Yeah?
And similarly, let me ask
you the following question.
As I make the well deeper
and deeper and deeper,
holding the width, and make it
deeper and deeper and deeper,
does the number of states
increase or decrease?
It increases.
If you make it
deeper and deeper,
the radius of that circle is
getting bigger and bigger.
There are more points where this
circle intersects this point.
So here's another one.
We've got one here, one here,
one here, three solutions.
And the number of
solutions just goes.
Every time we click
over a new point
by increasing the radius of the
circle, we get a new solution.
We get another bound state.
But here's the thing that
I really want to focus on.
Let's make the well
less and less deep.
Let's make it shallower
and shallower.
At what depth do we lose
that first bound state?
We never do.
Right?
There is no circle
so small that it
doesn't intersect this curve.
In a 1D, finite well potential,
there is always at least one
bound state.
There are never
zero bound states.
This will turn out not to be
true in three dimensions, which
is kind of interesting.
But it's true in one
dimension that we always
have at least one bound state.
And in fact, you
can decorate this.
You can use this and
fancy it up a bit
to argue that in
any potential in 1D,
there's always at
least one bound state
unless the potential
is constant,
I mean any potential that varies
and goes to zero infinity.
Yeah?
And so we still don't
have any numbers.
But we know an awful lot about
the qualitative structure
of the set of energy eigenvalues
of the spectrum of the energy.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what
happens if r is bigger
than pi or y is bigger than
pi and you get two solutions?
PROFESSOR: Great.
So when we have two solutions,
what does that mean?
Well, you've got to bound
states, two different energies.
Right?
It's a good question.
Every solution here corresponds
to some particular value of y
and some particular value of z.
But those values
of y and z are just
telling you what
k and alpha are.
And so that's
determining the energy.
So a different
value of k is going
to give you a different
value of the energy.
So we can just eyeball
this in particular.
Let's look at alpha.
Alpha is just e.
Alpha squared is just e.
Yes?
So here's a quick question.
If alpha is just e,
and alpha l is y--
So this is our y value.
y is roughly alpha,
the width, which
means it's roughly the
energy square root.
So this value,
the vertical value
of each of these intersection
points on a given circle
corresponds to the
square root of the energy
times some coefficients.
So which state has the
largest value of the energy?
Absolute value, which
state is most deeply
bound on this circle?
Yeah, the first one.
Right?
Because it's got the
largest value of alpha.
So this is nice.
We see that the
first state always
has a higher value of alpha
than the second state,
which always has a higher value
of alpha than the third state.
And every time we
add a new state,
we make the depth of these
guys the binding energy
of the already existing states.
We make it just a
little bit deeper.
We make them a little
more tightly bound.
And only eventually
then do we get
a new bound state appearing.
And what's the energy
of that new bound state
when it appears?
Zero energy.
It's appearing
just at threshold.
OK.
So we'll explore that in more
detail in the problem set.
But for now, let me
leave it at that.
Questions?
Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said that
this can be generalized
to any nonconstant
function that you'd like.
So there's always going to
be at least one bound state.
What about, like
with delta function?
PROFESSOR: Excellent question.
What about the delta function?
We're going to come back to
that in just a few minutes.
It's a very good question.
So the question is, look,
if any potential that
goes to zero infinity
and wiggles inside,
if any potential like that
in 1D has a bound state, what
about the delta function?
We briefly talked about that.
So we're going to come back
to that in just a few minutes.
But it's a pressing question.
OK.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the energy is
zero, but that's not possible.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
OK.
Good.
So let me talk about that
in a little more detail.
So I wasn't going to
go into this, but--
So when new bound states appear,
so let's consider a point where
our r0 is, let's say,
it's just the right value
so that r0 is equal to pi.
OK.
And we see that we're just about
to develop a new bound state.
So let's think about what
that bound state looks like.
So this is the new bound state.
And I'm going to put
this in parentheses
because it's got bound state.
And we say at threshold.
OK.
At threshold, i.e.
at the energy is roughly
zero, and r0 is equal to pi.
So this is really what we mean.
This new state,
when r0 is pi and we
have a solution on
that second branch.
Cool?
So what does this wave
function look like?
What does it look
like when you have
a wave function
that just appeared?
It's just barely bound.
Well, first off, what
does it mean to be bound?
Let's just step back
and remember for now.
What does it mean
to be a bound state?
It means you're an
energy eigenfunction
and you're localized.
Your wave function
falls off at infinity.
Now, if it falls
off at infinity,
do these guys fall
off at infinity?
These wave functions,
sure, they fall
of with an exponential damping.
And in particular, let's
look at the right hand
side of the well.
This new bound state is
appearing just at zero energy.
So out here, what is
the wave function?
It's e to the minus alpha x.
But what's alpha?
Zero, right?
There it is, zero.
So this is e to the minus alpha
x where alpha is equal to 0.
This is constant.
So what does the wave
function look like?
Well, the wave function,
again over the same domain--
Here's 0, l.
And here's the value zero.
We know that in this
domain it's oscillatory,
and in this domain,
it's constant.
And actually, since we know that
it's the first excited state,
we know that it does this.
So if we make the well
ever so slightly deeper,
ever so slightly
deeper, which means
making the radius of the
circle ever so slightly larger,
we will get a nonzero value
for the alpha of this solution.
Right?
It'll be just tiny.
But it'll be nonzero.
So we make the well just
a little tiny bit deeper.
We get something.
OK, good.
So what's going to happen
to the wave function?
Well, instead of going flat.
This is going to curve.
It's got a little more energy.
There's a little more curvature.
So it curves just a
little tiny bit more.
And then it matches onto a very
gradually decaying exponential.
OK.
So what's happening as we take
this bound state, the second
bound state, and we make the
well a little more shallow?
We make the well a
little more shallow.
It's a little less
curved inside.
And the evanescent tails,
the exponential tails
become longer and longer
and longer and broader
until they go off to infinity,
until they're infinitely wide.
And is that
normalizable anymore?
No, that's not normalizable.
So the state really
isn't strictly localized
at that point.
It's not really a
normalizable state.
And just when the state
ceases to be normalizable,
it disappears.
We make the well
just a little deeper,
and there's no
state there at all.
OK.
So this tells you
a very nice thing.
It's a good bit of intuition
that when states are appearing
or disappearing, when states
are at threshold as you
vary the depth, those threshold
bound states have exceedingly
long evanescent tails, and
they're just barely bound.
OK?
This turns out to have all
sorts of useful consequences,
but let me move on.
Did that answer your question?
Good.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in this case,
the radius, as you say,
is proportional to the length.
Right?
But also we have intuition
that as we increase
the length of the
well, the energy's
going to keep increasing--
PROFESSOR: Fantastic.
OK.
So what's up with that?
Right.
So the question is this.
We already have intuition that
is if we take a finite well
and we make it a
little bit wider,
the ground state
energy should decrease.
The energy of the ground state
should get deeper and deeper,
or the magnitude
should increase,
another way to say it.
Right?
That was our intuition.
So let's check if that's true.
What happens if I
take the ground state
some value of the
radius, and then I
make the well a
little bit wider.
Well, if I make the
well a little bit wider,
what happens to r0, the
radius of the circle?
Well, if I double the length
of the well, the width
of the well, then
it will double r0,
and it will double the
radius of the circle.
So if I make it
wider, r0 gets bigger,
and we go to a bigger circle.
And what happened to the
energy of this state?
Yeah, it got deeper
and deeper and deeper.
And meanwhile, as
we make it wider,
as we make the well wider, the
circle is getting bigger again.
And we're going to get
more and more states.
So as we make the well wider,
holding the depth fixed,
we get more and more states.
As we make the well deeper,
holding the width fixed,
we get more and more states.
And so how do you trade off?
If I make it twice
as wide, how much--
So here's a good question.
Suppose I take a well,
and it has n states.
Suppose I then make
it twice as wide.
What must I do to the
energy so that it still
has the same states
with the same energies?
AUDIENCE: Divide it by 4.
PROFESSOR: Yep, exactly.
I've got to divide it by 4.
Because I've doubled
the length, that
means the radius
has gone up by four.
But I get exactly
the same solutions
if I just bring this out.
Well, that's almost true.
So if I put a
factor of 1/4 here,
that's almost true, except for
the value of y is unchanged,
but the alpha hasn't changed.
Sorry.
The alpha has changed
because there's an l.
So y is fixed.
But alpha's changed
because of the l.
So the reason that it's
useful to write things
in these dimensionless forms is
that you can see the play off
of the various different
dimensionful parameters
in changing the answer.
Other questions.
OK.
So a couple of comments.
So the first is let's
just check to make sure
that this makes sense.
We have already
solved this problem.
We solved this
problem a while ago,
but we solved it in
a particular limit.
We solved it in the limit that
the potential one's arbitrarily
deep.
Right?
So when the potential
one's are arbitrarily deep,
holding the width fixed,
that was the infinite well.
That was the first
problem we solved.
So let's make sure that we
recover this in that limit.
So what happens as we make
the well arbitrarily deep,
holding the length fixed
or the width fixed.
So if we make this
arbitrarily deep,
v0 is getting arbitrarily large.
That means r0 is getting--
We've got a huge circle.
So what do these
solutions look like when
we have a huge circle.
Let me not do that here.
Let me do that here.
So if we make the
potential nice and deep,
Let's think about what
that plot looks like.
So again, that first plot looks
identical with the tangents.
So on and so forth.
And what I want to do is
I want to dot, dot, dot.
OK.
So this is way up there.
So these guys are basically
vertical lines at this point.
So for very, very large values
of y, and in particular,
for very large values that are
of order the gigantically deep
radius r0, what does
the circle look like?
So what does the second equation
look like, the second curve?
Well, again it's circles.
But now it's a gigantic circle.
Yeah, exactly.
If it's a gigantic circle,
it's basically flat.
It's not exactly flat,
but it's almost flat.
It's a circle.
So what are the values?
And here's the key question.
What are the values of--
Did do that right?
Yeah, OK.
Good.
So what are the values of the
curve, where we get a solution?
The values now of
z, are just exactly
on these vertical lines,
on the separatrices.
The value of z is at pi over 2.
and 3pi over 2.
And then another one at 5pi
over 2, and so on and so forth.
Right?
So what we find is that
the allowed values of z--
Sorry.
kl, yes, good.
--allowed values of z are
equal to 2n plus 1 over pi.
Whoops 2n plus 1
over 2 times pi.
So let's just check that.
So n is 0.
That's 0 1/2 pi.
n is 1.
That's 3/2 pi.
Good.
So these are the
values of z, which
says that kl is equal to 2n plus
1 upon 2 pi or k is equal to 2n
plus 1 over 2l, which is
the width of this well
because it's from
minus l to l pi.
So is this the correct answer
for the infinite square well?
Are these the
allowed values of k
inside the well for the
infinite square well?
Almost.
Instead of 2n plus 1, it
should just be n plus 1.
We seem to be missing about
half of the energy eigenvalues.
AUDIENCE: That's
only the even ones.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, thank you.
This is only the even ones.
We started out saying, oh, look.
Let's look only
at the even ones.
Where do you think the
odd ones are going to be?
Ah, well the odd ones,
so this should be k even.
So what about k odd?
Well, we know the
answer already--
Whoops.
Odd, that's an odd spelling.
--should be equal to 2n
over 2l plus 2 over 2l.
Whoops.
2 capital L, pi.
OK.
This is our guess
just from matching on
to the infinite square well.
So what does that mean?
Well, that means it should
be this one and this one.
So when you go through this
exercise on your problem
set and you find the
solutions for the odd,
and you repeat this analysis
for the odd ground states.
What should you expect?
Well, you should
expect to find this.
And what do you
think the curves are
that you're going to use
int he graphical solution
to do your
transcendental equation?
Yeah, it's really
tempting to say, look.
It's just going to be
something shifted, like this.
OK.
So these are going to be the odd
question mark, question mark.
OK.
So you'll check whether that's
correct intuition or not
on your problem set.
OK.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What about the lower
end of these states, where
it won't have gone
off high enough?
Is that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
So that's a really
good question.
How to say it?
What we've done here to
make this an infinite well--
So the question, let me
just repeat the question.
The question is, look, what
about all the other states?
OK, it's true that
r0 as gigantic.
But eventually, we'll go
to a large enough z, where
it's the circle coming
down over here too.
So what's up with that?
What are those states?
Where are they?
What do they mean in terms
if the infinite square well?
Well, first off, what are
the energies of those states?
AUDIENCE: Very low.
PROFESSOR: They're
very low in magnitude,
which means they're close
to what in absolute value?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
They're close to zero.
So they're at the top
of the finite well.
These are the states bound at
the top of the finite well.
the bottom the finite well.
But how many states are bound
at the top of the finite well
when we take the limit that
the well goes infinitely deep?
Yeah, none of them.
Right?
So when we make the
well infinitely deep,
what we're saying
is, pay no attention
to the top of the well.
Look only at the
bottom of the well.
And if it's really deep, it's
a pretty good approximation.
So that's what we're doing here.
We're saying, look.
Pay no attention.
There is no top of the well.
There's just the bottom.
And look at the
energy eigenvalues.
Does that make sense?
So what we're saying is if
you have a preposterously
deep well, the energies
of a preposterously
deep well should be
a good approximation
to the low-lying energies
of an infinitely deep well.
Because it's way up there,
what difference can it make?
And that's what we're
seeing work out.
Did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Wait.
I might have this backward.
But when it says the high
energy instead of looking right
at the top of the well--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, good.
So this is an important
bit of intuition.
So when we say this
is the energy zero,
and the potential has
a minimum at minus v0,
and we're measuring the
energies relative to zero,
then the states at the
top of the potential well
are the states with
energy close to zero.
And the states at the
bottom of the potential
well are those states with
the energy of order v0.
cool?
And what are the energies
of all these states?
They're order of v0.
Right?
Because this is--
Are they exactly v0?
No, because this isn't linear.
It's actually a circle.
So there's going
to be a correction,
and the correction is
going to be quadratic.
If you work out that
correction, it's correct.
The depth above the
bottom of the potential
is correct for the energy of
the corresponding infinite well
problem.
I'll leave that to
you as an exercise.
Other questions?
OK.
So there's another
limit of this system
that's fun to think about.
So this was the
infinite well limit.
What I want to do is I
want to take advantage
of the observation we made
a second ago that as we make
the well deeper,
we get more states.
As we make the well more
narrow, we get fewer states.
To trade that off, consider
the following limit.
I want to take a potential
well, which has a ground state.
What does the ground
state look like?
So the ground state wave
function is going to be--
So here's zero.
And here's
exponentially growing.
Here's exponentially decreasing.
And if it's a ground state, how
many nodes will it have inside?
How many nodes will
the ground state have?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
Good.
OK.
So the ground state will
look something like this.
We more conventionally
draw it like this.
But just for fun, I'm going
to draw it in this fashion.
In particular, it
has some slope here.
And it has some slope here.
Oh, shoot.
Did I?
Yes, I did.
Dammit.
I just erased the one thing
that I wanted to hold onto.
OK.
So there's my wave function.
It has some
particular slope here.
And this is the ground
state wave function,
with some energy.
I don't know.
I'll call it this.
Now, what I want to
do is we've already
shown that as we make the well
more and more shallow and more
and more narrow, the
energy of the ground state
gets closer and closer to zero.
But there remains
always a bound state.
There is always at
least one bound state.
We proved that.
Proved, as a physicist would.
So I want to do that.
I want to take this seriously.
But here's the limit
I want to consider.
Consider the limit that we
make the potential v goes
to infinity, v0, while
making l go to zero.
So what I want to do is I
want to take this thing,
and I want to make it
deeper and deeper, but more
and more narrow.
If I do this
repeatedly, eventually I
will get a delta function.
And I will get a
delta function if I
hold the area of this guy fixed.
Yeah?
So if I do so, holding the
area under this plot fixed,
I will get a delta function.
Everyone cool with that?
So let's think, though,
quickly about what's
going to happen to the
ground state wave function.
So as I make the potential,
let's take this wave function,
and let's look at this
version of the potential.
So as I make the
potential deeper,
what happens to the rate
of the oscillation inside
or to the curvature inside?
It increases.
Right?
So the system is oscillating
more, it changes more rapidly,
because phi double
dot or phi double
prime is equal to v minus e phi.
It oscillates more rapidly.
So to make it deeper,
the system tends
to oscillate more rapidly.
However, as we make
it more narrow,
the system doesn't have
as far to oscillate.
So it oscillates
more rapidly, but it
doesn't oscillate as far.
So what's going to happen?
Well, as we make it more
and more narrow and deeper
and deeper, we again have
the wave function coming in.
And now it oscillates
very rapidly.
Let's do it again.
The wave function comes in,
and it oscillates very rapidly.
And the it evanescent tail out.
And now as we have a delta
function, exponential damping,
it oscillates extremely rapidly
over an arbitrarily short
distance and gives
us the kink that we
knew at the very beginning
we should expect when
the potential is
a delta function.
Right?
From our qualitative
structure of the wave function
at the very beginning
we saw that when
we have a delta
function potential,
we should see a kink
in the wave function.
Because again, if we have phi
prime prime is delta function
discontinuous, phi prime
is the integral of this.
This is a step, and
phi is continuous.
And so here we have
a step function.
We get a discontinuity
in the second derivative.
Here we have a delta
function in the potential,
and we get a discontinuity
in the first derivative
if we get a kink in
the wave function.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Would we
get a jump there?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Say again.
For e1?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Would we get a jump?
PROFESSOR: Very good question.
So let me do this
more seriously.
Let's do this more carefully.
So the question is, for
the first excited state,
do we get a jump?
Do we get a discontinuity?
What do we get for the
first excited state?
Right?
So let's talk about
that in detail.
It's a very good question.
Example v is equal to
minus v0 delta of x.
Now, here I want to just
warn you of something.
This is totally standard
notation for these problems,
but you should be
careful about dimensions.
What are the dimensions of
v0, the parameter of v0?
It's tempting to say energy.
That's an energy.
But wait.
What are the dimensions
of the delta function?
AUDIENCE: Length.
PROFESSOR: Whatever
length right?
Because we know that
delta of alpha x
is equal to 1 over
norm alpha delta of x.
So if I write delta
of x, which is always
a slightly ballsy thing to
do because this should really
be dimensionless, but if
I write delta of x, then
this has units of 1
over length, which
means this must have units
of length times energy.
OK.
Just a little warning,
when you check your answers
on a problem, you
always want to make sure
that they're
dimensionally consistent.
And so it will be
important to make sure
that you use the
energy times the length
for the dimensions
of that beast.
So my question here is,
is there a bound state?
So for this example,
for this potential,
the delta function
potential bound state, which
again is this guy, is
there a bound state?
So again, we just ran
through the intuition
where we made the potential
deep and deeper and deeper,
v0 divided by epsilon
over width epsilon.
So v0, in order for
this to be an energy
has to be an energy
times a length
because we're going to
divide it by length.
So this is going to
give us a delta function
potential in the limit.
We have an intuition
that we should
get a bound state with a kink.
But let's check that intuition.
We want to actually
solve this problem.
So we'll do the same
thing we did before.
We now write the general
solution in the places
where the potential is
constant, which is on the left
and on the right.
And then we want to impose
appropriate boundary conditions
at the interface and at
infinity, where these are going
to be normalizable, and this
is whatever the right boundary
conditions are.
So we are going to have to
derive the appropriate boundary
conditions.
So let's just do that quickly.
So phi with definite
e is equal to a--
So in this region
in the left, it's
either growing or
decreasing exponential.
So ae to the alpha x plus
be to the minus alpha x.
And this is x less than 0.
And ce to the alpha x
plus de to the minus
alpha x for x greater than 0.
So first off, let's
hit normalizability.
What must be true
for normalizability?
Yeah, they'd better be
converging to zero here
and converging to zero here,
which means that c had better
vanish and b had better vanish.
OK.
So those guys are gone
from normalizability.
And meanwhile, if
this is symmetric,
what is going to be true
of the ground state?
It's going to be symmetric.
So a must be equal to d.
Great.
So a is now just some overall
normalization constant,
which we can fix
from normalization.
So it looks like this
should be the solution.
We have an exponential.
But there's one more
boundary condition to fix.
We have to satisfy
some matching.
We have to satisfy the
boundary conditions
at the delta function.
So what are those?
What are those
matching conditions?
So we can get that from the
energy eigenvalue equation,
which says that
phi prime prime is
equal to h bar squared upon 2m.
Sorry.
Get your dimensions right.
So it's 2m over h bar
squared v minus e.
In this case, v is equal
to minus v0 delta function.
That's very strange.
So minus 2m over h bar squared
v0 delta of x minus e--
I pulled out the minus.
--so plus e phi.
So this must be
true at every point.
This of course, is
zero everywhere,
except for at the origin.
So what we want to do
is we want to turn this
into a boundary condition.
And we know what the
boundary condition is.
If v is a delta function, that
means that phi prime prime
is also a delta
function or proportional
to a delta function.
That means that phi
prime is a step function.
And how did I get that?
I got that by integrating
phi prime prime.
You integrate a delta function,
you get a step function.
Well, that's cool.
How do we figure out what
step function discontinuity
gives us?
Let's integrate.
Let's integrate right
across the delta function
and figure out what
the discontinuity is.
So let's take this
equation, integrate it
from minus epsilon
to epsilon, where
epsilon is a very small number.
And that's epsilon to epsilon.
So what is this going
to give us on the left?
Well, integral of
a total derivative
is just the value of the
thing at a value to the point.
So this is going to be
phi prime at epsilon
minus phi prime
and minus epsilon.
What does that mean?
The difference
between the derivative
just after the origin and
just before the origin.
This is the discontinuity
for very small epsilon.
of the derivative
at the origin at
the delta function.
And we already expected it
to have a step discontinuity.
And there it is.
And how big is it?
Well on the right
hand side we have
2m minus 2m upon h bar squared.
And we're going
to get two terms.
We get a term from
integrating the first term.
But over this narrow
window, around,
let's say epsilon was here, over
this narrow window we can treat
the wave function as being
more or less constant.
But in any case,
it's continuous.
And this is a delta function.
So we know what we get from the
integral of the delta function.
We just get the value v0
phi at the delta function.
Phi of the zero at the
delta functions, so phi 0.
We get a second term, which
is plus the energy integrated
against phi.
The energy's a constant.
And phi is continuous.
So this, whatever else
you can say about it,
is roughly the
constant value of phi
at the origin times the
energy times the width, which
is epsilon.
So plus-order epsilon terms.
Everyone cool with that?
So now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to take the limit
as epsilon goes to zero.
So I'm just going to take
that the discontinuity just
across zero.
So this is going to give
me, of this gives me
the change in the
slope at the origin.
OK.
The derivative just
after the origin
minus the derivative just
before the origin is equal to--
These order epsilon
terms go away.
--minus 2m upon h
bar squared v0 phi.
So that's my continuity.
That's the condition
for continuity
of the derivative and
appropriate discontinuity
of the first derivative
at the origin.
And so this, when we
plug-in these values
of this form for
the wave function,
when we take a derivative,
all we're going to do
is we're going to
pick up an alpha.
And so when we work
all of this out--
I'm not going to go
through the algebra.
You're going to go through
it on the problem set.
--when we take this condition,
when we impose this condition
with this wave
function, it gives us
a very specific value for alpha.
This is only solvable
if alpha is equal to mv0
upon h bar squared.
Good.
So let's just check the units.
So this is momentum times
length, momentum times length.
This is mass.
This is an energy
times a length.
So this has overall units
of, p squared over m,
overall units of 1 upon
length, which is what we wan.
So that's good.
So we get alpha is
equal to mv0 upon h bar.
And that gives us the
form of the potential.
And it also tells us that the
energy, plugging this back in,
is equal to minus h bar
squared alpha squared upon 2m,
which we could then
plug-in the value of alpha
and solve for v0.
So what we found is that
there is a single bound state
of the delta function
potential, which
we could have gotten by
just taking this limit.
It's a fun way to
rederive the same result.
It's a nice check on
your understanding.
So we find that there's
a single bound state
of the delta function potential.
Now, what about an
odd bound state?
We assumed at an important
point that this was even.
What if I assume
that it was odd?
One node, what if we had
assumed that it was odd?
What would be true
of the wave function?
Well for odd, this would be
a, and this would be minus a.
So the value of the wave
function at the origin is what?
Zero.
So that tells us the value
of the wave function is zero.
What's the discontinuity?
Zero.
So it's as if
there's no potential
because it has a zero right
at the delta function.
Yeah?
But that means that this wave
function, an odd wave function,
doesn't notice the delta
function potential.
So is there a bound state?
No.
So how many bound
states are there?
Always exactly one for the
single isolated delta function.
On your problem
set, you're going
to use the result of the
single isolated delta function,
and more broadly you're
going to derive the results
for two delta functions.
So you might say, why
two delta functions?
And the answer is,
the two delta function
problem, which
involves no math--
Right?
It's a totally straightforward,
simple problem.
You can all do it right
now on a piece of paper.
The two delta
function problem is
going to turn out to
be an awesome model
for the binding of atoms.
And we're going to use it as
intuition on your problem set
to explain how quantum
mechanical effects can lead
to an attractive force
between two atoms.
See you next time.
[APPLAUSE]